diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für spezielle intelligente speziell
begabte gewisse sachen habe ich aus dem
bett oder älter husain geführte
breitbild also gewaltige sind limitiert
sie es ist wirklich sehr viel gutes
passiert würde zu bereiten denn dann
wird eröffne ich auch mehr spaß auf
dazu machen herzlich herzlich herzlich
danke wovor aus dem heute gibt sie sehen
[Musik]
das resultat ist recht erschrecken
noch fragen
die anfänge
roger schawinski bett 1945 in zürich
geboren
arbeiter core tier 1 4
unsere mittelstand scout hat jutta
feldmann die eu dazu und ist aber dass
sich bescheiden ich sie zwei oder drei
zimmer wohnung sie sind vater und mutter
und die schwester jacqueline also das
luxuriöse verhältnis sie der junge roger
schawinski kommt 1958 ins realgymnasium
und fliegt gleich wieder raus
die leistungen sind ungenügend zwei
jahre später beginnt schawinski mit der
handelsschule am freudenberg in zürich
ich glaube niemand hat dank dass der
rutsche dann später mal zum 1
medien tycoon wert und so wie thoma
bekannte figur tranche profi wurde
vor allem französische haben wir ein
sehr starker und orange ist zuverlässig
im leserservice also tiere ungeeignet
sind die mineralien torschluss vorteil
minister aber es hat mich geküsst und
mitnahmen ist nie auf doch er hat dass
er so mit den schultern zuckt und hat
dort aber werden dass nicht so viele -
macher aber schon die tatsache dass sind
dass man später widerruft ausflug ist
ich habe irgendwo hatten schock wurden
dann noch ein versuch die matura zu
schaffen
in nur sechs monaten will schawinski
dafür den stoff von drei jahren nach
pauken und ich habe einfach das erste
mal im leipziger ich muss mich prächtig
und muss seine sache mehr
der professor zur zeit hat sie haben die
besten filme gemacht die tränen
aufgegangen und ich bin echt weggang
module auf platz 29 in seinem galopp
durch farbe stand die augen oder western
im nachhinein minister ist eintönig
primaten wäre kruska erstmals als kühl
kann ich mich echte gebe sehr viele
reiche volkswirtschaftsstudium in st
gallen
schawinski fühlt sich unterfordert
spielt studententheater organisiert den
hochschul ball und macht zum 50 jährigen
jubiläum des lions club bei einem essay
wettbewerb mit thema frieden schawinskis
aufsatz kommt unter die besten sieben
weltweit
also ich wirklich schwierig sieht aus
lateinamerika und in wien zu 87 inso ist
das richtige york sie willigt ein
das ticket hinein dies verneint die
damen des sv kevin grewe und peter nach
san francisco und dann plötzlich so
komische loebstraße nachfragen müssen
hippies das taxi von journalistischen
karriere
das hat das wo sich die suite mitteilen
dass grauens extremst und das damit
erster artikel wurde und um täter die
blaue blume von san francisco und der
schweiz mitteilt skeptisch ganz sprache
[Musik]
[Applaus]
53 jahre ist das her
dazwischen liegt ein ganzes
journalistenleben roger schawinski
empfängt einer seiner letzten talk-gäste
fernsehdirektorin nathalie wappler nur
noch lang werden
ich mache das ja ich mache dem iphone
also ist zwischen strafstoß und absolut
mein hey die ganze situation das sieht
ja wohl schmeckt er dass die sagen sich
begegnet und dass ich dann wenn die
rechten die positionieren er kommt eifer
ich spiele den thron angeschlossen
kritischen interviews vieles was sie da
sagen wo die show gerade sicher ist das
nicht immer ganz sympathisch aber es ist
mein job und ich bin heute eigentlich
eine wohltat ist dass ich manchmal nicht
unbedingt sympathisch werde für mehrere
offiziere
er polarisiert ohne rücksicht auf
verluste als journalist als
geschäftsmann als mensch der mann ist
geboren um zu polarisieren aber dadurch
schöpfte auch die energie der habt um so
erfolgreich zu sein was sie nie
fähigkeit mit b finale der gleichzeitig
kursiert derzeit mit mehreren leuten
steht sie an die öffentlichkeit treten
und rolf der großteil selbst lud wurde
ich jetzt für zeige das sind eher
wegbegleiter frieden er freunde aber
wäre wenn er sich ungerecht behandelt
fühlt oder wenn er fehlt dass ich ihn
verändern oder andere gemacht hat denn
ich habe gerade los dass auch ins
gewissen emotionaler mensch
wenn man irgendwie lenkbarkeit nach der
melodie zeigt dass die gasse der hawks
wieder zusammen trinkt bier
ich habe gemerkt dass darüber später
wieder lang das ist eigentlich normal
[Gelächter]
also es geht noch nie so einfach
die sagen einfach damit überaus
schwierig weil die eine oder andere
kritische frage stellen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
1968 roger schawinski zieht es wieder in
die usa
auslandssemester in michigan
da kann ich selber kreiert und wir sind
so im ausland club sie auch so ist eine
studentin und den transit opfergaben so
junge attraktive puerto ricanerin und
habe total verwirrt also sich großartig
sie ist völlig also ein anderer war co
mein tor ist anfangs eigentlich
unterhaltung für sie und für mich als
fremdsprache ist ob es ist spät dran
diesen besser kennengelernt habe da habe
ich bemerkt dass es interessanter
intelligent hatte am schluss wird ein
studio ist verabschiedet
beim er am flughafen und ich weiß noch
ich habe geweint weil ich hatte das
gefühl es gebe in der schweiz so geht's
nicht
aber dann sind die für ihre frau die für
ihre policen sind so unglaublich sie
dennoch so horx märz immer total offen
er also wieder aufmerksam
du musst du musst mal kann er das wort
verlinkt
[Musik]
ich war noch bei meiner tante in der
apotheke das weiß ich noch ich habe dort
geholfen und da hat mein bruder
angerufen die usa telegramm bekommen und
dieses telegramm waffenruhe wo er gesagt
hat ich bin unterwegs hat er gesagt wenn
er ankommt und da habe ich das ist heute
das ist schon da musste schnell nach
außen und dem empfangen und dann habe
ich gesagt okay ich weiß nicht wie meine
eltern reagieren
meine mutter von der arbeit gekommen und
dann ist das scheiße da das hat sie
nicht erwartet schawinski 24 jahre alt
heiratet die 19 jährige puerto ricanerin
priscilla colon
[Musik]
nach den flitterwochen ziehen rossi und
riss sie die schweiz in eine wohnung in
albisrieden das geld ist knapp
eine von diesen frauen die mit mehreren
mitschülern waren hat uns besucht und
ich habe vorn gemacht und dann hat sie
meine eltern erzählt stell dir vor die
lage so schlecht dass sie leute ein
musik kriegen und dann meine eltern
haben sogar angerufen es war sehr teuer
wenn man sie anzurufen sind franken
minute und dann haben gesagt du kommst
sofort nach hause zu schicken denn
ticket weil du kriegst nicht genug zum
essen
die schau nicht traurig dass sich wenig
geld hatte oder so eigentlich war
verliebt und es war alles eine große ja
alles war neu
[Musik]
ich habe glück dass sich ältere kann
wohl nie irgendeine erwartete wie ich
jetzt sage was ich brauche
die support fund hatte großartige hat
allensbach das heißt ja immer thematik
betroffen
und das hat mich stärkt das hat mich
beflügelt bayern antreten müssen eltern
aktiv tierarten wie sein leben die
ältere kam es gegen 12 tragen und dass
man ihre stetige hat hobby-historiker
jahr zur hand und treiben dort
zusätzlich als 550 am dienstag hat mick
jagger hat irgendwie sind träumen können
vom hat sich eine immer noch leicht
gemacht und als vier jahre durchfallen
irgendwie speziell und ich habe es immer
als schlimm
und das muss ich so sagen es tut mir so
leid weil es seine großartige 90 sie
noch verlauten ließ habe nicht versucht
rehabilitierung sage ich mal ein stück
leben
ich staune und ich versuche das beste zu
machen und versuchen auf die artemis
zeigen dass wir als familie weixing für
die leistung gezeigt
[Musik]
schawinski ist der erste seiner familie
der studiert - amerika da habe ich wohl
ein beatboxer amerikanische universität
und da nicht dass claire hat folglich
auffälliger schraubt was die bringe und
ausgeschrieben und es geht da rein wo
das verbessere sagte und variieren
sawickis brief landet auf dem tisch von
erich gysling damals jüngstes mitglied
der neu gegründeten rundschau redaktion
und interessant werden
doch mache und dann ist ja zuerst
fernseher hat war mit dem krieg und
eingefunden
doch das ist eigentlich interessant mit
dem römer durch user bis anfang so
beginnt roger schawinskis karriere beim
fernsehen ohne viel journalistisches
vermissen die hand bis zum radio gemacht
learning by doing
die meisten wo damals ist fernseher
rosel dass auch dort wo die rundschau
und standard hat wenig journalistische
farbigkeit und tue ich das eigentlich
außerhalb verständlich dass bezahlt habt
mir probiert einmal rückgänge bei der
rundschau zu erstellen das hat man so
der hersteller weiter zu kommen
er hatte zu viel wollte er hat ihm ist
sehr viele dieser mensch das sogar wenn
er geschlafen hat die mitte von der nach
wie vor ist gesprungen und da hab ich
gesagt was ist los und da gesagt ich
weiß was für eine musik nehmen kann für
den bereich stimmungen
mai für fenster und da habe ich gedacht
hast du nicht geschlafen gesagt doch ich
aber geschlafen aber im schlaf arbeiter
arbeit 1972 südamerika ist in aufruhr
in argentinien erwartet man die rückkehr
des ehemaligen präsidenten juan perón
[Applaus]
roger schawinski will dabei sei
glücklicher zufall
reinhard meyer sein jugendfreund aus der
handelsschule arbeitete zu jener zeit
als journalist in buenos aires hatte
termin verschafft und ihr erlaubt was
für themen und eigentlich ist das für
ihn und da für mich ein glücksfall
sie will sich unglaublich viel passiert
in alland grad ident gmbh
und so berichtet jungreporter schawinski
mehr oder weniger zufällig darüber wie
kontron aus dem exil nach argentinien
zurückkehrt
unsere linie nicht zufällig dort was mir
war die cca drauf und durch und können
nun noch zwei proben dort müssen alle
elektrisiert sie will dass ich ins regie
und wer hat's natürlich erfreut wie
längst hat das von dem fernseher haben
wir ein geschäft daraus machen
[Applaus]
auch als ein jahr später in israel der
jom kippur krieg ausbricht ist roger
schawinski vor ort
tel aviv eine stadt in frieden doch wenn
man genauer hinschaut erkennt man das
nicht weit von hier ein äußerst blutiger
krieg geführt werden das ist schwierig
sie wild und ich war morgen von tel aviv
mit irgendwann offiziere müssen
offiziere vorträgen formation da nicht
so verfahren betrifft zum beispiel mit
der journalistischen karriere geht es
steil aufwärts
doch die ehe mit priscilla schlittert in
eine krise
wer mehr bekannt und ich hatte das
gefühl die beziehung war nicht so
wichtig wichtig war die karriere
einmal habe ich ihm gesagt das hättest
du nicht machen sollen oder und da hatte
mir gesagt mir bist du mir so etwas zu
sagen da habe ich ihm gesagt ich bin
deine frau aber wenn das nicht genug ist
dann haben wir angefangen uns nicht
sogar so verstellen ich habe das gefühl
gehabt er wollte er eine
südamerikanische ihre beziehung frau
bleibt schön zu hause und man nach
wasser wie
beim schweizer fernsehen probiert
schawinski etwas völlig neues aus
ein sendeformat dass es bisher so nicht
gegeben hat wie viele einzig sport deren
aktionen sie das geistes geht des
wirtschaftsmagazin doch ich bin teilt
sie von verschiedenen redaktionen die
augen das machen hört will sich im
vorjahr bevor die tagesschau und so groß
wie die lauter werdende bank betrogen
und dann hatte ich nehme taxi und das ok
mögliche wie es momentan mit wirtschaft
von opel sondern wirtschaft und dann ist
die griff auf den kosten sturz das haben
wir schon mit über wo natürlich aber man
hat der kassensturz am anfang wieder so
ernst glaube hat dank neuer tisches an
den ball versucht und das sind auch
anderes handeln versucht wurde und nach
einiger zeit sind sie wieder was wurde
nicht so der kassensturz die neue
sendung hat bald den ruf die dinge beim
namen zu nennen und viele natürliche
nährstoffe das ist die werbung und so
sieht das produkt wirklich aus ich ihres
produktes und andere kriterien zu mensch
auf dieser zeit und ich habe das dann zu
raab moderiert nur fliegen ist teurer
als taxi fahren jedenfalls so ist es in
der schweiz heute wir verglichen die
tarife in verschiedenen schweizerischen
und ausländischen städten und das
resultat ist recht erschreckend räuber
hatte annika wie das geht und wie die
völlig unbeholfen sie und meine erste
bilder
nach zwei jahren kassensturz wechselt
roger schawinski vom fernsehen zum print
er soll der mikrozeitung tat neues leben
einhauchen der karriereschritt fällt
zusammen mit der trennung von priscilla
[Musik]
weiß ich noch da hat er mir gesagt du
kannst mich jetzt nicht verlassen
das fand ich richtig geld zu verdienen
ja gesagt ja ich habe den nicht
irgendein geld gehabt dann kann ich auch
weggehen jetzt das ist aber eher froh es
ist also eine es war so eine komische
sache
ich wusste der schritt machen aber ich
weiß dass es das war was er eigentlich
auch wollte er wollte wieder frei sein
[Musik]
das ist jetzt 100 wunderbar aber ich bin
neugierig auf neue erfahrungen
vielleicht darf neue erfahrungen mit
anderen frauen
der andere ist bei einem scheitern und
das ist sehr wichtig sie also haut hat
kaka und tony kanaan die fähre ging also
castro meistern
nachdem russen sind aus dem bezirks
gebäude hamburg sid - kleinkrieg machen
er hat mir eine palme ich mir immer
gewünscht aber geschenke nicht jemand
transistor wird er haben wollte
bei der tat die der migros gehört will
schawinski an den erfolg des kassensturz
anknüpfen und eine zeitung für
konsumenten machen
das team ist jung und die vorlaufzeit
mit vier monaten knapp doch der junge
chefredakteur setzt sich hohe ziele
es schaut bisher über wege jetzt zeige
dass er ein nach dem kassensturz das
citycar uhr also sein wie das schweizer
zx markt aufmischen
am vierten april 1977 erscheint die
erste neue tat
ich habe als junger journalist erste
werk das wort hyperaktivismus bedeutet
das ist vom morgen bis zum sport
ununterbrochen auf einen gang unterwegs
durch verführer zuhörer und zeiten das
ist so führt eine elfköpfige redaktion 7
12 bis 15
chefredaktor war dass er glaube dass
oder nase karten möglichst aus der
jugend journalisten 2003 ist er einige
worte taranto setzt nach gutem start
stagniert die auflage der tat bei 70.000
und die werbeeinnahmen bleiben aus
anderthalb jahre nach der lancierung
steht die zeitung vor dem aus das bad
wird auf 18 12 millionen verlust gemacht
das ist für micro langsam scheinen das
problem zum 21 natürlich als politisches
problem kann die geschwindigkeit zentral
und gezielt macht den reihen der zement
gezielt mit aufschnitt vergessen die
migros ich denn natürlich hat der neue
eigentümer der ik die etwa anders reisen
und dass ich ihre bürgerliche partei xii
das hängt natürlich relativ schnell
zwischen der ethik und migros zur
politischen spanien geklärt
probleme die mega geschäft mit dem mikro
der hand das nicht lästig geworden dass
wir zum teil eben aggressive
journalismus gemacht werden
chefredaktor schawinski verweigert sich
kurskorrektur und sparmaßnahmen er muss
gehen
die redaktion streikt nach schawinskis
entlassung
doch die tat ist nicht mehr zu retten am
25 september 1978 stellt die migros ihre
tageszeitung ein
[Musik]
nach der tat nimmt schawinski eine
auszeit auf der karibikinsel grenada und
kommt dort auf die idee die sein leben
prägen wird
wie keine andere frank schmidt
revolution statt um der halbzeitpause
studio der miditec augen dieses
radiostudios sie dass die junge
revolutionärer xi ist ein kleines radio
also dürfen sich meine kontrollieren und
dann machten die revolution wird und
dann hat das kriegsspiel thema schlaf
sich noch während sie in der karibik
befragt und dann noch nicht einfach der
gedanke dann abtreten
ich glaube schon kunst sie hoffentlich
gesehen war jeder königssee aber ich
habe meine schlussfolgerung daraus zog
dennoch nicht ganz einfach irgendwie
sofort für knorr und aufsehen weil die
schweiz fordern
oder dass sie das gut zwischen links und
rechts ist da es ist nur ein teilbetrag
des östlichen da irgendwo hat 17 uhr
halberg banken die ich auf der fdp cvp
ergangen
dann wird es einfacher für die 1000
finden und die millionenstadt erfahrung
habe ich das auch morgen umfragen ja
mein körper hält bauen
man kann nicht drei treffer und so
weiter und so fort so hat das ganz laut
mai in der verwaltung gegangen auf dem
hofe dann hat man also innerhalb von 3-4
monat des ganzen ist ein auftritt
schawinski findet einen investor und
lässt für die sendeanlage eine kaverne
in den berg sprengen
die antenne selbst ist ein 30 tonnen
schweres stahl ungetüm
technisch funktioniert über zwei werke
dienen könnten land bergland um 20h die
technik funktioniert wird kann eine
gefunden das ist james möchte haupt
chinesen haben wir uns in die contens
frisur und dann cremig denn das komme
dass ein mal überhaupt versucht mit dem
städte und kreise vor der wahl mit einer
riesen und linke zu 14 grad
damit aus der richtung zürich geschickt
christen münster oder folgendes prozent
größeren einstieg wird nie auf wir
brauchen oder eine bergen aber recht
hatte ich komme um gegen die mannschaft
einzuschlagen
das ist so
schawinski center ist einer von 3.000
radiostationen in italien aber die
einzige die über die alpen bis nach
zürich und darüber hinaus senden kann
am 28 november 1979 nimmt radio 24 den
betrieb auf illegal wie man im
eidgenössischen verkehrs und energie
wirtschaftsdepartement findet der erste
schließungs befehl lässt keinen monat
auf sich warten doch die radio 24 hörer
leisten widerstand
eine freie stadtverkehr los als
kostentreiber behörden etwas belanglos
von melos aussage ich bin mir nur noch
audio station haben wir interessierte
dann schaut er kläre zwangspunkte raums
recht schlecht programmlicher technik
spritzig wie eine sturzflut approach to
sie die briefe wenigen man plötzlich
hört mein gemüt wo es ein zu großes 50
jahre geehrt worden oder 30 sind auch
zum anderen zur äußerung innert weniger
tage unterschreiben 200.000 leute eine
petition gegen die schließung von radio
am 29 dezember bringt schawinski die
unterschriften in begleitung von 5.000
radio 24 fans nach bern
[Musik]
dass ich mir vorher nachher die
italienischen behörden wollen den sender
trotzdem abschalten
als sie allerdings am vierten januar
versuchen das radio 24 studio in
cernobbio bei como zu schließen müssen
sie unverrichteter dinge wieder abziehen
die extra aus der schweiz angereisten
anhänger verzeichnen einen etappensieg
der streit zieht sich über jahre hin
radio 24 wird zwischen 1980 und 81 3 mal
geschlossen und wieder geöffnet von iris
stoff ganz unter und ich hatte eine frau
laura situationen oder sagen dem schluss
dass sich oder kurz vor der schließlich
nicht alle mitarbeiter total deprimiert
sie sind im studio im studio es auch
schlimm wie die hornets ii und mini
aufgabe ich dann nur irgendeine lösung
zu finden und man so heiß prozent geht
chance verbrechens lese muss ich das
eine prozent finde man sich lange staus
konzentriert und nicht geduldet oder
mich gefragt was da alles schlimmes mehr
passieren
[Applaus]
schawinski mobilisiert seine hörer am 26
januar 1980 kommen tausende auf dem
zürcher bürkliplatz um gegen das
drohende ende von radio24 zu
demonstrieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist der 14 für journalisten nicht
sehen will
auch sieht was man schuldig so viel hat
das hat mir dann zum vorwurf gemacht
dass man mir dazu gelernt
daran musste ich mich nicht berufen
[Applaus]
nach drei jahren hat schawinski den
kampf gegen das monopol gewonnen 1983
erhält radio 24 die konfession um aus
der schweiz zu senden
wissen und glauben werde wiederum haben
schon zu beginn seiner radio 24 zeit
lernt roger schawinski inhalt wie
trocken
1981 heiraten die beiden
noch im selben jahr wird roger
schawinski vater hat sich großartig
wunderbares glücklich aber leider stand
jeder vergangenheit sehr gut der schmerz
ist eine gefragte kriegen auch die ganze
sache
das sind der eigentliche sache wo
begrüßt schmerzen team ganz oben und ich
stehe da begrüßen
wie das gehen einer von ihnen
bald nach der trennung von ina finisher
wind geht zu seiner zürcher jugendliebe
rachel claire zurück schon zweimal waren
die beiden zuvor ein paar nun beim
dritten versuch soll es klappen
die hause gegen costa rica jetzt bleiben
wir zusammen und jetzt wäre eigentlich
das so richtig gut war eine
vorreiterrolle gut werden aber wenn man
im winter der verzierung sehen ob jetzt
warum rief sind wie sie fehler gemacht
haben erklärt wie man effizient aus
ungarn jetzt ist es so richtig und das
sind wunderbare zieht es sie und dann
plötzlich vorhand darauf zu wandern hat
die seite spielraum kritisch
und sie hat einfach glück ob sie wird
jetzt sterbe und bitrix sie sollen zu
hause
ich war gerne die fragen wurden oder ob
jede ist hat sie sogar erlaubt die
katzen an die hand
das will ich jetzt einfach aber ich
wünsche dir dass du mal die letzte
stunde
jetzt ist fertig
[Musik]
das mit dem trojaner wo sie verschiedene
religionen geht ist viel zu gut ist nach
einem jahr ist dann verschiedene
irgendwie skripte für die wacker darf
dann ist wieder offen
1993 lernt schawinski gabriella sontheim
kennen kurz nachdem er auch gestorben
ist der ping langsam wieder normaler
mensch wurde und dann ist sie plötzlich
vor mir standen wie ein fernsehporträt
und morgen am meisten los ist sie nach
210 tonikum zu starten die wunderbare
waren von mir und sagt du ich bin
verhindert sie verbrauchen
es steht wie perfekt sie gab sie damals
zusammen und da bin ich da nicht anders
und meisten wohl frühzeitig muss die
frau unbedingt wie hat sie kaiser ich
habe doch sei er dankbar
dein name weil ich in szene dann weiß
ich aber ich weiß einfach nur und bin
ins telefonbuch geholt
das modell mit dem buchstaben g
und so weiter und irgendwann bdp es so
und ich weiß es
so heißt am sonntag ist dann es
telefonisch mit dass er gott seminar
können speicher aber hatte und hat er
mit jüngeren grund und dann haben
abgemacht und sind zusammen spazieren
zwar kommen
1996 heiraten roger und gabriella im
jahr darauf kommt tochter lea zur welt
wie das nächste große projekt schawinski
gründet das erste regionalfernsehen der
schweiz
1994 die tele züri auf sendung roger
schawinski will mit neuen billigen
produktionsmethoden im engen tv markt
eine nische finden
die energiegeladene lieder schaftliche
menschen auf erzählt also mehr denn da
mitmischen das feld auf und mache das
großartiges fernsehen tele züri datum
sortiert linie 8 kamera zeigen
micky maus kamera bei mir grosse
schweizer fernsehen das grosse schweizer
fernsehen das größte bedenken kann den
abstieg sieht etwas 4 bei der die lieder
schaffte die energie vom forscherin
skript
als partner holte winski ringe und
tamedia 1 bot eine verbindung die von
beginn weg unter keinem guten stern
steht die konzernleitung von tamedia ag
und welt amedia telezüri beteiligen
schawinski verwalten mit dem michael
ring
aber das ist natürlich die verwaltung
hat sich das meistens klar machen dass
man krank sondern nur das klima nicht
unbedingt siegen
telezüri findet sein publikum ist aber
wirtschaftlich nicht erfolgreich
trotzdem denkt schawinski schon weiter
an ein nationales fernsehen allerdings
ohne die beiden partner ringe unter
media
die haben eigene pläne an den erfolg von
tele 24 glaubt darum außer schawinski
kaum jemand bewusst zerstört wird soll
es werden
längst haben ja zum wahltag noch traurig
mikroskopischen system sowie tele 24
trotz allem auf sendung
die thüringer blieben und das einfach
gut machen oder noch besser machen aber
national fernseh zu machen und noch
stärker mit dem schweizer fernsehen tele
24 ist eine geld verbrennungsmaschine
eine million franken pro monat verliert
schawinski nach dem start des senders
steht da nichts unter panikattacken 8
oder und rußbach schweißgebadet und da
ich auch nicht was passieren und so
nämlich eine schlaufe zeitpunkt sie
wolle meisten wirklich der druck spürt
der wirtschaftliche druck und zürich
roger schawinski verkauft balkon gruppe
für 92 millionen franken an tamedia zur
geltung gehören radio 24 tele 24
telezüri sowie weitere unternehmen die
schawinski radio cscs credit suisse
ökonometrie prozent jetzt wurde aber
auch ein freak alle machen und nachher
hättest reste von unternehmen zusammen
mit credit suisse tamedia verkauft und
danach wochenlang gefeilscht aber am
schluss hat man gefunden
90 millionen und einer bedingung tele 24
muss sofort geschlossen werden
auf schawinskis kosten das ist so eine
sache wohl nicht man gern zu machen sich
also fort proto es ist fertig habe mir
gesagt und in dem moment dreht sich der
regel ab und sagt meine tätigkeit ist
weg sie als moderator im fernsehen
benötige der stadt oder region zürich
eigentlich der chef von dort zwar weiter
wichtig elektronische medien und dateien
oder fisch gibt es nur ganz andere ist
auch schon immer aber dann ich plötzlich
so eilig auch noch in der nacht der
letzten acht vom tele 24 sat 1 wartet
auf dich eigentlich nur pass und ozon
oder zwei chefs nicht von positiven
haben die täter in teilen auch das
angeboten auch das geschäft sei sein
werde
im dezember 2003 tritt roger schawinski
den job als geschäftsführer von sat 1 an
kein mensch kannte roger schawinski
roger schawinski war für uns ein
unbeschriebenes blatt ist es hatte im
sommer in artikel von ihm gegeben von
ihnen geschrieben gegeben in dem er sich
kritisch über die führung von sat1
geäußert hatte das ist das was man von
roche kannte und dementsprechend groß
war die aufregung was neues aus der welt
der medien
schawinski löst hoffmann als sat
1-geschäftsführer kennst du schon gehört
da heißt es jetzt haben einen neuen chef
ja natürlich und sowie ist menschlich
bisschen hart aber als mediennutzer muss
ich mit auf dem neuen chef einstellen
sie sich in jobs und brot ich ess des
lied ich sing jetzt kommt neuer herzlich
von ihren chefs mit der hacke zum teil
hoffe ich mich lustig harald schmidt
verlässt sat 1 kaum hat schawinski
angefangen und das ist freut auch sie
das ist ja unglaublich waren goethe und
schiller stage wäre es geworden weil sie
mal aus der schweiz
das ist unser neuer chef-trainer sehen
das mit harald schmidt das hat ihn
getroffen weil er selber bewunderte
harald schmidt ja auch er wusste ja wie
gutteil schmidt ist
wenn er wirklich etwas wollte da hat
roche sehr wahrscheinlich in seinem
leben häufig die erfahrung gemacht dass
ihm das gelingt und dann auf einmal
diese ablehnung zu erfahren das hat ihn
getroffen dass er das harald schmidt das
zum anlass genommen hat sein kommen zum
anlass genommen hat zu gehen
doch der schwierige start ist bald
vergessen
roger schawinski baut sat 1 um setzt auf
information und einen neuen führungsstil
das gibt es szene wo nicht orange knox
ebner ist zweiter bus aussteigen and und
in den schnitt rumänen stürzte bei der
kata teams verhalten sondern ihn
abklatschen großartige schnitt haben sie
ja gemacht und so großartig wie haben
sie das gemacht wo er glaube ich habe
aus zeichnet die torte und daraus ist
dass ich das nie domina gestürzt und hat
sich den kater persönliches
geschäftsführer vorgestellt und in die
aktuelle top bis wo der kater wo sie 20
bis 30 jahren noch erlebt das ist
typischer sexy schawinskis größte erfolg
ist aber die einführung der telenovela
verliebt in berlin
[Musik]
aus verliebt in berlin wurde ein
gigantischer erfolg nicht nur dass die
serie selber sehr erfolgreich war
sondern es strahlte auf die sendungen
davor und die sendung danach aus auf
einmal gab es bei sat 1 was es vorher
nie gegeben hatte
eine sendung vor der primetime die
funktionierte und die dafür sorgte dass
auch die primetime besser funktionierte
auch finanziell geht die rechnung auf
der gewinn springt innerhalb von drei
jahren von 4 auf über 200 millionen euro
er war der letzte große senderchef und
die letzte große zeit dieses
privatsenders ging mit roche zu ende
im talk mit der sp chefin bleibt
schawinski für seine verhältnisse zwar
kein skandal zum ende der karriere und
ich weiß dass ein weiterer schritt auf
dem wagen bedingungslose greifen das ein
tolles und das muss irgendwie
irgendwohin wo man dann können hinein
und was wissen dass man sich nicht nur
definiert wir sie in die rolle der
öffentlichkeit sondern will ist ganz
anderes auch bei anderen privaten
madymo das dorf am fuße des b c gruppe
roger schawinski zurück am ort seines
größten triumphs
[Musik]
jetzt also das ist schon die highlights
siegen.de mich woanders vlaanderen
[Musik]
das ist irgendwie nur start wieder solo
auf gewissen ich glaube es braucht gar
nicht aber erstmal weil wir sie schon
bereit
wir haben 240 medien schafft es
vielleicht anders entwickeln
viele etwas kühler sich gut ich bin
verblüfft was ich alles hat der vater
was ich alles auch gerne machen und wenn
ich selber so revue passieren man sich
das vorstellen dass man nicht das gefühl
dass heute gesehen hat so ein erfülltes
leben füllt und sonja buck das war dies
jetzt einer machen die da kommen die
sich aufführen oder geröstet
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von dr
genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergamotte cremiger genuss seit 1922